on va voir si vous souvenez de vos
émissions des thèmes que vous avez
traité evelyne thomas
on va faire une interview laurent fait
ou à faire
[Musique]
je ne pense pas catherine que ça soit
une très bonne idée d'avoir mis laurent
baffie et d'armoires et pique nique aux
quêtes un gros déconneur braqueront le
fouille à sortir attention evelyne
thomas vous le dites fait ou pas fait je
suis rousse est alors fait je suis fou
amoureux de mon chien fait pas fait oh
c'était pas intitulé comme ça mais c'est
chiant
le doigté sur un magnifique les deux
hommes
j'ai bien ça je vais passer ma vie pour
moi aussi dit chat vous verrez les gens
vous embrasser et oui j'aurais des pluie
de pétales de roses
attention je me moque de mon hygiène
l'habite de mon mari a un goût déjà fait
je fais des choses que personne ne fait
avec la ville de mon mari je fais des
choses que personne ne fait feu sont pas
très précises et qui a dit c'est ouais
ça devait pas est intitulé comme ça je
fais peur aux gens je cultive ma
ressemblance avec une star c'est
l'actualité même je cultive sa
ressemblance
je cultive ma ressemblance avec moi-même
non pas les noms je communique avec l'au
delà
je communique avec l'au-delà mais c'est
lui qui paye je suis fakir n'ont pas
fait j'arrive à moto sucden
m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu